Nói 22 tháng năm 2018, phòng cảnh sát hình sự công an thành phố đảnh nắng cho biết
Đơn vị vừa bác hình cấp với Thị Kim Sau, sinh năm 2018, chú phần xân trà
Thị Phố đảnh nắng, là vừa của nạn nhân đầu CT để đưa trà về hình ví dích người trong vua an đặc biệt nghiên trọng sế gia tại phường an hải
Chứ đó, 22 năm 2018, Nói 3 tháng năm 2018, mỗi thái bảo, sinh năm 2018, có sinh của nạn nhân đầu CT đã bị khởi tổ về tổ vẻ tuổi dưới
Tuy nhiên, quan trình đu trà cho thấy lời khai của bảo mô tổn với hiện trường, đồng thời Kim sau có nhiều biểu hiện bất miên về kinh tế và thể đổ só khai chí của trồng
An chai dù của bảo là mướng khi hát của có biểu Việt bất thường
Nhi hai mì tháng năm 2018, sau và hát đã bị đưa về cơ quan công an làm việc sau khi quen khó trối tổ, cả hai đã thường dẫn hình ví
Lời khai cho thấy, sau đã khi hồn với ông T từ năm 2018 và từ sinh bô tổn, Kim sau đã sử dụng anh em bảo sức hạc ông T để chiếm đoạn tại sản thẩn chi còn bản bảo kế hạc và hướng sẽ lời lựu cho bảo
Theo kế hoạc, giọng sáng 2019 tháng 2018, bảo đã dùng dưới tình công ông T từ nghiênh Bất thình, Kim sau đã gọi bảo quay lại, chân bị sánh phụ khí và mực cửa cho bảo vệ nhà, cả sau và hát đều trình kiến vụ việc không gân ăn mà còn dù dụ bảo, sau khi bảo dưới đi, Kim sau tiếp tục dục hát dùng bản uổi tình công an nhân, sau đó, Kim sau đã soa dấu với hiện trường và hùng dẫn hát chế dấu hình ví
Các bạn được chào sát biển với Thị Kim sau giữ phải chào chùm yêu, sử dụng và giúp sức lịch cửa, đời mời hát, gió thực hiện hình vì khi chơi đủ mề bà tuổi sẽ xem sét át sụ mẹ pháp đều vào chứng giá giữ theo quy địch